[Applause]
hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
Leeds and this week on winners on a
Wednesday I wanted to introduce you to a
good friend of mine called Matt Sims
Matt came to the crash course last year
and as a result he has secured a deal
which is now making him 60,000 pounds
profit per year
he's also bought two houses in South
Wales he's got a lot of other really
interesting things going on
so please welcome my good friend Matt
Sims hi Samuel great to have you on
windows Wednesday Matt I've known for
quite a while but when did you when did
you join the Academy sign up the Academy
in the autumn last year okay so it's
been what six months or so yes yep
great and you've secured a deal that's
making you how much money per year
at the moment fifty to sixty K net and
we'll scale that up over the next five
years it's not your typical deal right
well it is and it isn't so it's a rent
to rent deal yeah but it's it's homes
with wheels on so we have a bigger
business alongside which is the higher
in sale of motorhomes
so camper vans or RVs and this is a
storage of those business why don't you
just give us a little bit of background
into what the business is yeah and what
you were doing prior to getting involved
with arch I think so I spent 20 odd
years in events sold that set up a
Motorhome sales business sold that and
moved into higher solder there was a
huge demand for people that wanted a
higher a holiday home that was mobile
we've grown that over the last three and
a half years very successfully we went
back into sales started selling them
we've started maintaining them and the
one gap we had we talked about people's
motorhome journey was the storage of
them and I always wanted to have a
storage business because I thought well
it's pretty easy money if there is such
a thing and and that's the business
we've now started so it's myself and my
partner we the two of us we run it
together and it's a rent to rent deal as
I say where we we are renting an
existing storage business which was run
down a bit
the owner was pretty motivated to get
out and we asked the right question
at the right time and took it over we'll
talk about how you got the deal yeah in
a moment but it's a really interesting
concept to do a rent to rent on a motor
home it's not that I mean I've never
ever heard anyone do that before he's
I'm having a thing called Yukon denier
so yeah we do that as well so that's how
we've grown the business so we started
with three motorhomes memorize these
things are fifty five thousand pounds
each yeah so they're not they're not
cheap and they're a depreciating asset
and we ran 28 last year we're based in
Bristol so fairly close to places like
Glastonbury so you can imagine
Glastonbury Festival is a huge week for
us and we have been busy finding owners
that want to have an income from their
motorhomes
so they use it for their holidays we
store it we look after it and maintain
it we hire it out and we we do a 50/50
split on the income when it's not on
hire this is the beauty of this model
it's not costing us anything we only pay
them when it's out earning an income so
it's it's a rent to rent with a
Motorhome and what we've now done is a
rent to rent on and so I was familiar
with that concept yeah but never thought
of it in terms of property just I just
thought well it's a motor home is yeah
and then we met properly and and started
working together I went to the crash
course and thought well that's what we
do with the motor homes which rent to
rent yeah and with a little bit of
knowledge that came what I mean I came
with a huge amount of knowledge from the
crash course but there was a little bit
of confidence that gave me that the
crash course gave me and it gave me the
ability to ask the right question at the
right time to do a rent to rent on this
storage facility which for me felt like
a much bigger thing than a motor home
yeah you know something I was inheriting
100 not customers and a massive
potential and yeah that's that's how
that's how we've grown the business so
what we've got these kind of I call them
pillars in our business where wherever
you are in your motor home journey if I
can call it that we've got a product
that fits the customers need and it was
really interesting when I had my
boardroom session we have Lord Sugar
I said to Lord Sugar
the best thing to invest in obviously
Lord Sugar invests in property or I do
probably doesn't what do you think the
best time property the best thing is to
invest him and he said but actually I
think the best thing to invest in is to
invest in what you know not to find what
you know to find what you're familiar
with and then see if you can make money
doing that and I think what you've done
which is really interesting is you've
got a background in motorhomes you've
got a knife for storage and things and
you were looking at that but you've
taken the principles that I've taught
you about property and you've employed
them to motor homes and storage units
and I'm making significant amount of
money doing that but what advice would
you give to someone else are you
suggesting that everybody should do what
you're doing or what was your voice
speak to somebody that was watching this
that was thinking motor home I think a
motive is a great industry I love it and
passionate about it I wouldn't say
suggest everyone gets into that but as
you say it invest in what you know and
learn more about you know what did the
the niche and the sector you're in
that's key is to keep investing in
yourself and keep learning because
there's still loads I don't know there's
still lots you don't know you know and
and the fact that I know you're very
open to continual learning and I and I
am too and that's that's really
important that the thing for me with the
storage site which is what sparked me
being here today and thank you for the
invite I really appreciate it it's kind
of a line in the sand for me it the
thing that happened for me was the
ability to ask the right question at the
right time and that came from the
training that you gave me yeah and also
having the confidence to ask it I knew I
had to ask and it was actually going in
and the background to this I actually
went to a different storage site first
and this guy I knew on today in fact he
approached us and I thought wow we're on
here we go
and honestly I walked out thinking I am
a complete waste of time if I thought
worse than that it was a disaster it
couldn't have gone any worse and I
literally left and thought you're
pointless Sims this is you're useless at
this it couldn't have gone any worse
and this guy if he's watching won't
mummy say it went really badly and three
days later I had this other storage site
to meeting planned I thought well let's
see how this one goes
and I kind of you know gathered myself
up and we went for again and it can look
on and easier it was brilliantly I
couldn't got any better so you won't win
them all and you'll get the knock backs
I only had one big knock back and one
big success I think I'm very fortunate
but actually I think I knew what to ask
yeah it was all about opportunity that
the personalities of these two
individuals I met were very different
their circumstances were very different
and their agendas were very different
and I mean if I'd look back now I knew
the first one was never going to go well
yeah I know that now yeah the second one
was always going to go well because it
was a totally different set of
motivation and it was a just a perfect
fit and it couldn't have gone any easy
oh you've heard us I'd go for now just
get in front of as many people as you
can yeah I think it's a it's a balancing
act between speaking does many of you
because you can but then also knowing
what to say and didn't say the right
thing and it's interesting we've we've
got a lot of people that have come
through the crash courses and just
generally our training that are in
business and they've up because we teach
people how to close property deals how
to make money in property and talk to
people or the confidence and all that
comes with it but people have applied
that to their business outside of
property and their businesses have blown
up and that happens all the time even
the things like Lease Option agreements
how to buy a house with no money people
apply that and there's people buying
businesses for no money and you know you
doing a rent to rent on different stuff
that's not necessarily property so I
just thought it'd be really interesting
to get you on the show really and tell
you about that what are your plans now
moving forward then so you say this one
deal is going to be making you a clean
profit of fifty to sixty thousand pounds
a year what's next for you so in terms
of that deal our focus is to invest some
of that money back into it year one yeah
we have a six year agreement I can see
that it will run on and run on but we'll
see we'll double those returns next year
so we're planned to in
testing we're happy to invest them this
year or big chunk of them anyway and and
then continually build it I now have an
appetite to find more similar businesses
yeah it's a very very lethargic industry
motorhome caravan storage very
complacent we've introduced a whole load
of extra services a whole lot of
creativity very very customer centric
business where it's not just about
storing your motorhome we'll clean it or
service it we'll fix it we'll look after
every month so as a whole it of bolt ons
are offering and it's very new in the
niche so it's getting a lot of attention
from the industry so that's our plan is
to grow that and I want to become
synonymous with being disruptive in that
industry yeah I already have a bit of a
reputation for it anyway and this you
know helps me do it I'm for me my
motivation is the customer there their
needs that's it so our appetite is to
see if we can copy and paste it I've
always loved the idea of copying and
pasting a business I recently gave a
talk a breakfast networking meeting
introduced by a friend of mine he said
this is Matt I've called his
presentation made a million lost a
million as kind of thanks that's true
and it was about copying and pasting a
business from the UK to the Middle East
and it kind of worked for a while and
then we lost a fourteen so I'm still
striving for that success my business
career has been described as for
funerals and a wedding so I'm waiting to
get married and we're on our way I can
feel it so traditional property is
something else that we've we've started
moving into we set up a property
investment business limited company and
we're starting to buy up properties
focusing in the South Wales area so
we've already got property rented out
that's a very traditional you know
purchase and rent yeah buy-to-let model
and lease lease purchase options is
something else we're looking at our
coloured envelopes have been flying out
the door we've had some success with
that already yet - nailed and convert
anything so yeah lots of the stuff you
teach we're implementing but we're
really busy with our business so you
know and family and stuff takes time you
know then so it does take time it's
frustrating but how do you manage
because you know you're a busy guy
you've got a busy business you're buying
properties and renting them out in South
Wales
you've got rent to rent you've got now
getting Lease Option agreements
potentially on the go and then you've
also a family man
yeah you've had some your son's not
being well recently as well how do you
how do you manage all that and how do
you host it what's the trick to staying
focused among so many different
strategies that's a really good question
so I'm a big project planner I acutely
plan my time and my to-do list my to-do
list changes everyday and several times
every day and that helps keep me focused
I regularly get distracted and called
away into other things you'll know this
it's the same with every business owner
certainly busy business owners and it
for me it's about I have I have two
piles this is a trick that someone
taught me important and urgent and I
deal with the important and sometimes
things move from one to another if
they're important they get dealt with
there are everything's urgent but only
when it becomes important will I deal
with it so that's my kind of finite part
what would you say the difference
between urgent and important is about
that high but give us an example if
something's urgent but not important
what so you want me to do something so
coming out would be important there
right maybe you'd like it might be
important to you yeah everything is
important to someone
yeah but is it important to me and what
I'm doing right now yeah and by doing
your task am I going to compromise
someone else with their importance I'll
say I have to evaluate that and and so
that's the criteria I shuffle them
everything is I think it's a really good
point because most people spend their
whole life just dealing with urgent
things I do
yeah reacting and dealing and running
around like a headless chicken dealing
with all the urgent things that coming
up and the things that their boss are
throwing at them but actually there's
probably not that many things that are
important but the important things don't
get done that's wrong one of the things
that I do is at the end at the beginning
of each year I write down five things
that are important that get done that
year so I'll say at the end of the year
if these five things happen I'll be
pleased with it's been a good year and
then pretty much the whole yeah I just
focus on those five things and
everything else is kind of irrelevant
these are the five things but I think I
think it's a really good point so
heartless erotic pleasure I'll drill
that down into my every day though as
well so you know setting up a be hag or
a big hairy audacious goal as they say
across the pond is crucial for a year it
could be crucial for a quarter but
equally this little the minutiae of
everyday so my to-do list on the train
this morning was rewritten based on
what's important to do in the next two
hours hmm whilst I'm on this train where
do you buy your houses in South Wales so
we're in the process now okay so you
just sort of secured when you get into
complete yeah fantastic so that's
happening now so we have a yeah property
limited company that we've done it
through yeah what made you choose South
Wales I can guess what we're in Bristol
yeah far enough away that we can't deal
with them ourselves
yeah but close enough that makes
understanding and getting under the skin
of the area as you would teach
achievable so having that big day yes
was it felt more achievable to do it in
South Wales and so that's what I think
what is a big day
so I force people to do I know I know
everything I sell in the grass here yeah
was there DfE course yep and I I've been
in business a long time and I have no
issue picking up the phone not actually
laughing at this up myself here I have
no issue picking up the phone speaking
to anyone but actually picking up the
phone speaking to an estate agent it was
just it's always nerve-wracking little
it's bizarre it's just weird yeah and
and I I'm an up shake now thinking of
that moment
and it was so real and I remember
sitting on the grass and just literally
holding my phone so why am I like what
is wrong with me yeah you know and I
think is I mean I mean I'm 47
I think it's reality has been probably
30 odd years of wanting to do it and
never really done it interesting and I
think it was that moment where I just
went over the edge and dived in now and
so the big day was all the viewings and
we had I think 12 planned and we came
back in the room there to report back
how many viewings have you got and I
came in at that point three you know
it's not that and you said Matt that's
not good enough
I said okay I'm pretty tough with that
yeah this to me more than I've ever done
you know and we have dabbled in property
in the past but it's been very passive
and so we went we broke again went back
out we regrouped as a workgroup kind of
encourage one another one of the guys in
our group have got 10 and I thought why
me what if he can do it I can do it
so offer went and then came back as were
12 and it was just again the right
question is saying to the agent so this
is what I'm looking for what else have
you got that you can show me and let
them do the work for you yeah and they
did and this lovely lady came back and
she said we've got six properties that I
think will fulfill your brief they're
all available to view don't me to book
them all in I said that would be
brilliant did that twice and we had 12
tour viewings and the end of the day you
know you can teach all the theory all
day long but ultimately the person that
books the most viewings and sees the
most houses and puts in the most offers
is the person is going to make the most
money of course now as long as you know
what you're doing you know which which
of course and I think 80 percent I'm
still learning I mean I'm making this up
you know to a point as I go along but
and that's where being in the Academy is
what will prove very useful to me is
that sounding board of other members in
the group yeah I can ask questions of
and you and your team as well so that
we're kind of yeah slow starting with
the traditional property side you say
slow start or the traditional side yeah
but you've got what a couple yes yes to
vote then of course the rental and the
[ __ ] storage site and some letters
going out for lease option agreement so
I think in pretty well I think you
definitely really
the fact that you made his 15 60,000
people make the edit yeah 5060 thousand
pounds off that one deal as a result and
that was a direct result of that
training we just totally yeah six months
ago this is genuinely true but before
going on the crash course and the DfE
course I would not have really
understood how a deal like that could
work
and I'm a I'm a pretty shrewd
businessman I'd like to think so anyway
and I would not definitely have not have
known how to execute the deal and the
parroting that you use I spoke to a guy
Sam who I know you live with in South
Wales and he was incredibly useful and
we're working with him on the property
in South Wales and he sent me a hole in
a heads of terms and said these are the
questions you should ask it's a
commercial rent to rent consider these
things well it was it was just for him
it was just one email with one
attachment it took him 12 seconds to do
for me that changed transformed
everything and that's the thing you
could you couldn't you can slave away
trying to do something yourself which
could take 12 years then someone else
has already done it um 12 seconds that's
really interesting and it opens doors
doesn't it so yeah already in the
storage side there's a there's a trade
association and they're taking an acute
interest in what we're doing and we've
got a meeting with them next week so it
that will open other doors as well so
yeah yeah you said there's our fun
fascinating
I mean the fact that you're you've been
in business a long time you're 47 you've
made you've made a lot of money you've
lost a lot of money yeah but you were so
nervous just phoning gonna say I don't
know and you know what I think sometimes
is easy and this is why I do things like
the financial freedom challenges because
when I went to America believe me I was
absolutely petrified and havin to go up
and knock doors it was horribly
uncomfortable but I think it's easy to
become comfortable and yeah you know if
you've been in business a long time when
you make some money or even if you've
then lost the money but it's easy to
kind of become proud and think I'm not
going to go to the crash course or oh I
already know that
and actually to say I already know that
is the most dangerous thing you can say
but if you if you're too comfortable and
you think you know everything then
there's no room for growth yeah and you
don't know what you don't know that is a
reality of it and the crash course is
such a great environment it's it's a
brilliant event but if it was just for
me it was a it's kind of wow you know
and you are so real and so genuine on
the course and the way you actually you
know go and find properties live in
front of everyone with no safety net
it's kind of this could go very wrong
and of course it doesn't because you
know what you're doing yeah it got but
what is amazing is you had us doing it
and I was finding dill singing well
that's a good one and you would you
they're genuinely saying if you find a
good deal I'll buy it you know earn
money in the room right now and it's
true it's not the thing is it's not
difficult I think the reality is
probably 80% of people that you engage
with do nothing yeah and yes the classic
pretos rule isn't it a principle of 8020
yeah and I want to be in the 20% and and
we are it well I am in the 20% and and
that's a that's key I think it's the
same as people watching this this
YouTube video right now there'll be some
people that go oh that's interest in and
and just do nothing and then there were
other people that go I'm gonna know more
and I'm gonna do that and oh my goodness
I'm gonna go view some properties
tomorrow and they're gonna take action
and you know all we can do is share our
story encourage people tell people that
it is possible yes offer the training on
how yeah that's great so tell us then in
your whole Middle East projects where
you invested and lost a load of money
what was the what was the that go into
the whole Baxter because I'm sure we
could talk about it for hours what was
what was the biggest lesson that you
learned in all that just to save us the
headache well copy and pasting a UK
business into another culture doesn't
work without whole little complication
and we kind of went for it with tea UAE
it's it's an area I love I've really
fell in love with Abu Dhabi spent a long
time over there
fantastic place fantastic people both
the expats are live there but the
Emiratis as well superb to deal with but
they deal in business very differently
to us yeah you know to the point that
six months after you've provided the
service they then want to renegotiate
what they're paying for it let alone pay
you and then you wait nine months to get
paid so you know then the thing is
though you say that obviously I've been
I've been to the Middle East but I've
done business there I copied and pasted
my property strategies I had worked in
the States
yeah and I'm confident than it could
work in most sort of Western countries
certainly so what do you think of that I
think yeah at what we were doing
worked the problem was people were
buying me and our senior team so and in
the UAE people the locals love to deal
with the senior business owner and
that's really important it's all very
much about relationship it's the same in
Asia and China especially the locals
they the local business people want to
deal with the business owner they don't
want to deal with your ops manager they
don't want to deal with a senior project
manager initially they want to deal with
the owner or the CEO or the MD yeah and
that was me and and a very small team of
us and so we had to be there to shake
the hands to set the relationships and
we couldn't always be there because our
UK business was the backbone of that
business and this was in 2008 when
things were changing here dramatically
there was a session that he brought over
that events corporate events so we we
were based at a huge Exhibition Centre
in Abu Dhabi and they were our sponsor
and yeah so it was a very much a copy
and paste business you know doing great
what happened no not all no not all was
that well I wouldn't I wouldn't have all
these lessons now
I'm not a fantastic experience I mean
even when we were losing money and
things were going wrong we were
defrauded quite significantly that was
the problem but yeah that whole
experience that was my life that was
given those were my life lessons and
that's been my story and my journey what
a brilliant way to look at mistakes
though and problems rather than saying
oh what a terrible thing happens to
learn from it
I think that's a real that's I think I
think if you take regret forward in life
then that's just a heavy bag you don't
want to be dragging around I've seen
people in property though they'll buy
property and it won't go to plan or it
will fall through or they'll have bad
tenants and instead of going well how
can I fix that and how can I make sure
that doesn't happen again
yeah just go oh my goodness this is
terrible this doesn't work this isn't
what I hope away but you can't do that I
mean I think based on what you've said
in property applying as property every
time you buy a property or you know you
or you do a deal or anything happens or
you go and pitch to a guy who makes you
feel like rubbish and says no it's the
same it doesn't work one of the stake I
think the key is to say well what can I
learn from that and how can I do it
better and it's it's know today know now
it does not necessarily going to be a no
tomorrow that the particular guy was
definitely a no tomorrow yeah and so I
walked away but I learned a great lesson
from it and now it makes me laugh yeah
yeah is it you have to you have to learn
those lessons yeah you really do I
always say celebrate your success and
discipline your disappointment but what
I think all that is get feedback from
your faul yeah yeah yeah it's on it
learn from it say okay well that's not
worked whatever what can I learn that it
means I don't do that again yeah and if
you find yourself doing it again you
soon realize yeah and you know what's
coming
yeah so what advice would you give as we
wrap up to someone watching this is
hungry and keen yeah to invest in
property yeah to grow their wealth
whatever reason where should I start
so start with you so invest in yourself
and learn and teach yourself you're
regularly say if you've got 30 grand to
invest in property where do I start
start with you so go and learn
and really learn how you can be that
person you want to be and understand
where you want to be yeah you know
having millions and millions of pounds
of planning the view from the balconies
great but you've got to build the house
first you have to you what I mean so
you've got it you've got to put the
Foundation's in first and that
foundation has to be you so I took I was
that person hungry motivated keen for 30
odd years and remained hungry motivated
keen and unsuccessful in the property
and it's only now am I start and I know
I'm not alone there's lots of guys and
girls my age that are just kind of
something happens I think in your mid
forties yeah where you wire things up in
your hair to go hang on a minute and I
did this I went through a divorce was in
living in a caravan for six months and
I've just kind of you know form well not
fought my way back but I've come back
into you know living a different way and
I think something happens when you go
through a life experience like that
where you can start building again and
you look at your life and go hang on a
minute I've been doing this wrong and I
started reading I'd recommend all the
board I'm a big audible listener reading
it for me it's something I don't
necessarily enjoy staring at the page as
my eyesight fails as I get older I find
my arms and no longer long enough so I
listen to books you know books I've
reached that Poor Dad
yeah the richest men of Babylon they are
that classical that's there people read
but they are a great place to start just
if that's all you do go and buy one of
them for a tenner inaudible and listen
to it and listen to it again the e-myth
for me was a book that I read three
years and it transformed my world and I
met the author and he signed my book and
it is the pages are folded it's
highlighted it is all about systemizing
business it's all about systemization
and everything we do now is all based on
the what's taught in that book
everything everything and and just learn
going learn go and soak it all up yeah
and then start to take action even if
it's small things that in the beginning
just take those baby steps that might be
going to a free event like the crash
course yeah it
might be going to a pin meeting I went
to one of my first pin meetings in a
long time a few months ago in January
yeah it was a course a crowded room
beginning of the year everybody went and
I was amazed how many people I knew in
the room yeah and they all came and said
hello and it's kind of wow this is great
yeah so it's taking those small steps
and what I found
always found in my business work life is
that success attracts success and people
want to talk to you and share your
success and be successful with you and
actually they want you to share in their
success as well absolutely because it's
that having that 18 so 18 players
attract 18 players and if you're not
there in that 18 you're just not going
to be given the opportunities I love
that I can really see your your passion
for learning you know if you're
continuing to learn and I think it's
fantastic thank you so yeah attend the
seminars read the books listen to the
audio CDs go to the networking events
get around successful people and what's
great you said success attracts success
or success breeds success yeah young as
as you go around successful people you
become successful now you're on here yes
I'm not going to be successful because
of your story and it just grows and
that's really what we're about so it
means you over the chance of being
successful yeah the thing is he was like
I said if you help other people get what
they want
yeah then you'll have what you want yeah
which is which is if nothing else which
is just the satisfaction yeah so that's
great thank you so much for being here
but a ledger and I look forward to
seeing you can sit you just smash it
yeah bless you mate okay thank you so
much for watching the video that is the
reason why I'm doing this your success
is my oxygen every single week we've got
people becoming financially free if
you'd like to see more success units you
can do that right here but what I'd
really suggest is why don't you come and
join us at the property investors crash
course come on on my guest completely
free and I'll personally be there for
two days to help you get started you can
see what happens right here what you'll
notice is all of these stories they all
start at the crash course so come along
my guests can't wait to see you there
peace out